[Music]
it was a star-studded night in Brooklyn
you're young all the hottest memes and
music came together on Tuesday for the
third annual Title X concert at the
Barclays Center tonight through music
title has brought together people across
generations and backgrounds who have
come together to support the people of
Puerto Rico
last week jay-z's global music platform
announced that all proceeds from the
event would go to benefit hurricane
relief effort cause that is near and
dear to JLo's heart the puerto ricans
stunner pulled out all the stops for the
occasion from her sexy all red outfit
can you come out here and help me take
off my clothes please and yankees
tribute
to where old-school hits like I'm real
and Jenny from the block and those
iconic booty-shaking moves there's no
question the 48 year old singer totally
dominated the night oh yeah it's good to
be in New York but JLo wasn't the only
lady in red the girls of fifth harmony
rocked similar ensembles boasting the
same fierce hue
so did hip-hop artist cardi bead who
brought down the house with her
jaw-dropping outfit and performance of
Bo doc yellow but no star shone brighter
than queen bee who hit the red carpet in
this stunning emerald green custom
walter mendes gown which featured a racy
thigh-high slit and cross cleavage cut
out it seems safe to say this was
Beyonce's best post baby look yet
[Music]